you try to enter competitions and you
try to do this and
and get validated and serve in different
ways
i think i got so rejected so many
times that i i didn't want i was like
screw validation
i love doing it i'm going to keep doing
it
and how long did it take you to write
the full script the first draft i
started it like
10 10 years ago
the first uh um maybe
a good um good draft
afterwards maybe like
eight months eight months or so
and then rewrite rewrite rewrite more
of of it so i don't even remember now
it's like so so so kind of like
long ago but i do remember when i was
starting it
because i was like i'm gonna try to
write my you know i wrote one feature
i was like i'm gonna do this this one
and then i got stuck and i took one
character
and wrote a short film on it and that
short film became my first short film
called balloons go pop um of it so
um i i used it as a a way to kind of
like
have a uh sort of like a sounding board
i i didn't have the pressure of like oh
i need to finish it in six months or
nine months i was just going through
exercises of it
and trying to figure my way out even
dialogue even um all the elements of
screenwriting
so i was trying to just get better at it
and then that over time i went back to
the story and shaped it up
until i felt confident that there was
something there
and that was a 10-year process from
script to screen
from script to final shooting draft
probably
six five
five six years yeah
okay so you knew at that point then this
is something i'm committed to
if this story still interests me that
many years later
i think so if you ask my wife and i
think i was so stupid
i was like hey if i die could you make
this film please
it's so dumb i don't know i just got so
like
i don't know i i don't even know why
it's just like
i just wanted to finish you know i
i just wanted to finish it um
because it took so much
to get it going and then i just didn't
want it to sit in
my drawer or sit in my laptop
so you know i i
enjoyed the characters and i just wanted
to kind of see it come alive and
again that's a selfish thing to oh i
wrote something i want to see it come
alive that kind of thing
and and and that's what i was driven at
because
like i said um i love to quit things
when
when when it doesn't feel right and this
never
not felt right so i just kept going and
going
um and even though there are
multiple many moments of of
you know it's brutal it's so it's a
brutal thing and i i want to kind of
and not say there's a myth of
of things there's a brutal stretch of
each of each of the process
to get it done how what are you doing
with your life
how's this happening how's the finance
going how are you going to make grant
where are you going to do this how what
if you don't get to this festival
what did this distribute you know all
these kinds of weird things that
you don't think about when you first
start writing and going oh
fade in you don't think then you're like
oh it just leads you on so
the journey has been um quite
quite interesting and uh you know but
sometimes when you see these things you
all see some person awesome they have a
movie and austin
they get another movie and all this and
it just so happens because i was there
and going how did this happen
you know i was like but my thought was
if someone else can do it
let me deconstruct this i could figure
this out and do it
so my only thing is
just trying to figure it out how to do
it so it's like
um i found one side of the rubik's cube
that's that's what happened and
um here we are just you know ready
sadistically enough ready to try to do
another one so
there you have it is it really that
selfish though
to want to make it i mean going back to
we talked about
it's also selfish to want to be promoted
in corporate america so yeah
it's really selfish um
maybe that's me just kind of like making
me feel better
uh because in the end it is a lot of
like
trying to you know
play to your ego play ego your own ego
and and and figuring out and and and
going
why do you want to do this you know
because i think it's a very honest
question to ask yourself
in the mirror why do you want to do this
um it's almost because
that's all you kind of want to do
and maybe feel like you're somewhat good
at
um not because if someone's telling you
that you're good at it is because you
feel
that it feels like you're good at it you
know
it's it's hard because it's like people
try you try to enter
competitions and you try to do this and
and get
validated and serve in different ways i
think i got so
rejected so many times that i i didn't
want
i was like screw validation i love doing
it
i'm gonna keep doing it you know it's
like but
what what does that take what does that
entail um
and when is it when is it enough so i'm
still trying to figure that out
you know as i go and one isn't enough
when do
do i have to write how many scripts do i
have to write you know how many
um movies that
would i will make me happy so then i'll
be like hmm
it's again just trying to make a
sustainable
career um that's just the goal my goal
so that's where i am at this point and
and trying to um sometimes it's a curse
because you're like
you know you wish
i i wish i would have gotten for that
that fourth more rejection to go okay
now i'm becoming a marketing assistant
or something like that and you're like
ah that'd be so much easier
gosh but now you're just like why am i
cursed to kind of
put myself in you know people i love in
this
this kind of like brutal um
uh kind of journey of filmmaking
you know uh but then it's a
privilege situation to
cry about creating so fan off camera as
we were taking a quick break you said
something about
possibly why why not just do this as a
hobby filmmaking screenwriting
yeah yeah i know you know you know
i ask myself that every day it's like
sometimes it's
it's it's just easier or
more precious when you keep something to
yourself as a hobby
you know it's like this going at it and
going
making it a living it's you know it's
not all 100
being creative it's you know like it's
85 business 15 percent being creative
and
and you have to um be okay with that you
know sometimes
and that and that is the the trick
that that could lead to that cynicism
you know and like and and
and things that that happened so
what ha you know so i asked oh
i should just keep writing because i
enjoy it but what's that need
you know what's that need so um yeah i
asked myself that every day
um sometimes i wish it was a hobby
but i'm too stubborn and too uh
you know crazy to um
that lets sleeping a sleeping dog lie or
something like that
so uh i keep pushing ahead
you